[Music]
foreign
for the Press preview then it's our
first chance to check out Sunday's front
pages and tonight uh we'll do just that
with the journalist and author Rachel
shabby who's joined by the political
commentator Benedict Spence great to see
you both uh we'll chat in a moment after
we've had a look at those front pages
beginning with the mail on Sunday
leading with Revelations protesters are
plotting to disrupt the king's
coronation using rape alarms
while the front of the observer looks at
the Fallout of Dominic Robb's
resignation this week the headline Tori
planned to politicize Civil Service
after Rob scandal
activist civil servants Target swella is
the headline of the Sunday Express
and the front of the telegraph also
leads on the Home Secretary with the
headline Braverman I'm ready to defy
judges on migrants
the Sunday Mirror features a report
about Boris Johnson's latest holiday his
fourth vacation since resigning as prime
minister
MI6 spy sent to jihadist Camp killed own
child reads the front of the Sunday
Times
and the Daily Star leads on tributes to
Star Barry Humphries also known of
course as Dame Edna average their
headline good night possums of course
and don't forget you can scan the QR
code that you see on screen during the
program check out the front pages of
Sunday's papers while you watch us
discussing them and to do that Rachel
shabby and Benedict spent how lovely to
see this Saturday evening lots to
discuss
um both of you why don't we start Rachel
with the front of the Observer and as we
were just saying the Fallout from
Dominic Robbs resignation continues
and it's important it's important to
remember in this blizzard blizzard front
page stories in uh conservative
supporting newspapers that
civil servants have done nothing wrong
civil servants have every right as do
all of us to work in a workplace that is
free from bullying and any form of
harassment and Dominic grogg was found
by an internal official inquiry uh to
have been engaging in humiliating
insulting Behavior
in several of his posts so that's the
important context but in that context
The Observer is reporting
um it's carrying a story from a former
cabinet office Minister a conservative
Francis Maude
who is saying well we should not shy
away from political appointments to the
Civil Service so what they're
essentially saying is in some of the
other newspapers are carrying stories
along these theme along this theme
um that civil servants are preventing
government from from doing their work uh
which manifestly is not true
um but it seems to be that the
government now is focusing on removing
the sort of checks and balances that we
have in this country
um and a part of a functioning democracy
one of them is a civil service another
is a Judiciary which again we're going
to be looking at stories
um around doing away with elements of
that as well but that seems to be the
focus very much across some across these
stories in tomorrow's papers okay um
well let's have a look at the front of
the Sunday Express because their
headline is activist in inverted commas
Benedict civil servants Target swella we
know that out of those eight complaints
only two were actually upheld would you
agree with Rachel then that no reform is
is necessary of the Civil Service
uh no I wouldn't agree I disagree with
Rachel the idea that the civil service
is uh performing its duties necessarily
to how it should be doing and I would
point to the rate at which uh the the
country is able to process uh Refugee
applications as being a very good
example of that uh now that can be
because potentially some people aren't
very good at their jobs but equally it
could be because the civil service has
not been given the resources that it's
that it needs you know you can say that
the Civil Service isn't doing its job
without necessarily saying that civil
servants aren't good at their job you
know they think those are two very
different things the front page of the
Observer suggesting that the
conservative party or the government
want to politicize uh appointments I
think what Francis Moore said is it's a
question of getting people in who are
effective but you can see certainly
given how this government has behaved in
the past how that could end up in uh
positions being politicized and uh
potentially people being given jobs
based uh not on how good they are but on
who they who they know but you know the
warning you would have to give to the
conservatives then is if you want to
free up
appointments to jobs be careful what you
wish for because you know we only have
about 18 months until there's likely
going to be a general election and the
odds are that labor will win that
general election at which point if
you've then changed the rules to make it
easier to put your mates into or
positions of authority uh you could have
the rug pulled from under you very
quickly and things might go in a very
different direction to how you want now
when it comes to suela Braven and
suggestions that there are civil
servants out to get her I would say if
Sue Ella bravman is good at what she
does and the Prime Minister considers
her to be essential at what she does
then she should have no real qualms
about civil servants going after her
because the Prime Minister will bat
those things away unless she's you know
accused of really egregious breaks of
the rules and is found to have done that
that's the way that politics works if
somebody is particularly useful to you
you get a little bit more leeway the
fact of the matter is Dominic Robb
ultimately wasn't very good at any of
the jobs that he'd had and I think you
know we'll touch on the Sudan story
later but I think you know go going back
to the to the Afghanistan debacle really
the question should be not so much
whether or not he was a bullying office
whether or not he should have had some
of the jobs that he actually had whether
he was in a position to turn around
civil servants and tell them what they
should been doing when he has been
proven fairly regularly to have been
pretty inept at a lot of his positions
yeah and of course he uh he uh was very
confident that he'd be found uh innocent
of these charges and and said to Sophie
Ridge here on on Sky News that he would
resign if it was uh felt that he had
been a bully and of course um so it has
uh come to pass he's had to stick by his
word let's move on to another story
about swella Bravo in front of the
Sunday Telegraph uh Rachel she's ready
to defy judges on migrants
absolutely and I would just point out
gently that what of one can be both
both and a bully
um but moving on moving on to swella
bravaman
um she wants to
I'm saying nothing I'm sorry
probably best probably best
under the telegraph front page
um
wants to get her illegal migration Bill
through uh it is going through
um another round of probably the final
round
um in in the House of Commons this week
and she is determined that the deal she
cut with Rwanda very dodgy deal uh not a
safe place at all
um she wants that to go through and so
she says now that she is prepared to
ignore
um European judges so that's at the
European Court of Human Rights in order
to start those deportation flights it's
not really clear how she's going to do
that
um or indeed how she's going to get that
through Parliament
um and it's obviously worth pointing out
that we have many crises in this country
the cost of living crisis the NHS is on
its knees social care is on its knees
um there are many many many things that
the government is failing at what we do
not have is an immigration crisis most
refugees most refugees most Asylum
Seekers 86 percent end up in neighboring
countries to the ones that they are
fleeing from and most of the refugees
and Asylum Seekers who come to Europe
uh do not come to the UK in fact you
know France just as an example had three
times more than the UK last year so it
is not a problem uh there is a problem
with people smuggling and putting um you
know forcing migrants to take incredibly
perilous and dangerous Journeys
um
at the hands of exploitative people
smugglers in dangerous boats across the
channel but that is because there are no
regular safe routes available so we
could certainly look at that but we do
not have a crisis anywhere near the
scale the government is suggesting and
the reason that they are pushing this
point so hard is that they don't want to
tackle or that aren't able to tackle any
of the other real crises that the UK is
actually facing okay Benedict your
thoughts on this
uh I mean on the subjects of whether or
not we have safe routes we do have some
safe routes but it depends where you're
coming from you know we have a perfectly
uh safe set of roots for people that are
coming from Ukraine we have hundreds of
thousands of people uh over a hundred
thousand people in this country who have
come from Ukraine and they had very few
problems theoretically we have a safe
system for people that come from
Afghanistan the problem is to go back to
the question of civil service reform it
doesn't work that's the problem we set
up
um a safe route the Arab scheme but very
few people can actually travel on it so
you've got thousands of people currently
trapped in Pakistan who are eligible for
the Arab scheme but who have no means of
getting here so it's all very well still
a problem and saying we're going to set
up safe you know safe routes as part of
this illegal migration bill but we've
had this in the past it doesn't
necessarily mean that the roots work
that they are effective so it's all very
well hearing that but putting it into
practice is another thing and I think
broadly speaking on the subject of
illegal immigration and immigration in
general yeah we had a net increase of
half a million million people into this
country last year many of them most of
them of course economic migrants and the
pressures that they put on are not
because they are just people coming from
abroad it is because we don't have the
capacity in this country why because we
don't invest in things like housing like
services so you know where you get the
issues is not necessarily because people
are coming over here and they're sort of
kicking their heels they have nothing to
do it is actually as Rachel says there
are many issues in this country that are
affecting people who are already here
who are coming over things like you know
can they get housing can they get places
at schools and that all comes down to
government planning over a longer period
of time now if you solved these issues
it's going to be a lot easier to bring
refugees from Afghanistan or other
places and to help them settle but if
you're sort of you know scrabbling about
going oh well you know people who are
already in this country are very unhappy
at the way that the NHS is working and
the way the schools are working
infrastructure breaking down short
shortages
um of food you know electricity
potential blackout that we had
um early earlier on in the year then of
course that's going to be a problem and
it does make sense then for the
government to turn around and try and
find a way of distracting us from all of
this sorry I can hear that you're about
to interrupt me um very quickly in a
sentence is Rwanda the right way to do
that though
no okay that was a very short sentence
well done thank you very much
um thank you both stay where you are uh
we're going to go to a break after which
we'll be taking a look at some more
papers including the coverage of the
death of Dame Edna Starr Barry Humphries
the front of the star says quite simply
good night possums discussing that in a
couple of minutes
[Music]
Follow The Sweet Sound of Birdsong on
Sky arts and discover the pleasure of
painting in nature oh it's gone join us
Jim and Nancy Meyer along with some
famous friends you're in a wildlife
right yeah but I knew it as we go on an
ornithological adventure with a
paintbrush
this is the best job I've ever had
because everything that I love art
birds and you
painting Birds Jim and Nancy Moyer
Wednesdays on Sky Arts
[Music]
I spent the last several years of my
life living out my wildest dreams I'm
coming for everything
available now to buy or rent and Sky
store Premiere my best friend is in
danger and you have to help me Super
Pets activate
see League of Super Pair it's available
now on Sky Cinema
uh-uh not yet ghost but the Moon
it's true I Can Feel The Love Can you
feel it too
quality ingredients for special moments
maybe Mark there you are it's a new moon
food love story is brought to you by
Tesco
Stiga presents the new autonomous robot
mower it's cable free
artificial intelligence in the garden
AGS technology
[Music]
Stiga
Garden Care
I've been a stun performer and
coordinator for over 15 years now
my external pair of eyes for all the
performers on set having control
psychologically is essential when you're
doing a big movie there are all sorts of
external pressures but you just have to
in your mind go somewhere comfortable
fire is an element you cannot mess with
a Victoria Plum it's all about you
delivery on over 13 000 items it's never
been easier to get your perfect bathroom
it's no wonder our customers Raiders
excellent and with our bespoke design
and installation service we can even do
all the hard work for you Victoria Plum
it's all about you
say hello to chase the digital bank that
makes everyday rewarding what does that
mean well you get one percent cash back
on your everyday debit card spending
like on this coffee absolutely
why is my debit card got no numbers on
it all your car details are stored in
the Chase banking app so no one else can
see them will I be speaking to a robot
if I call customer service nope just a
few tabs at the Chase banking app and
you're through to a real person oh sorry
so who are you again geez what a digital
bank that's already trusted by millions
of customers in the US how many millions
wow over 56 Millions
follow me say hello to rewarding banking
Chase
hello again part two of The Press
preview uh Rachel and Benedict are still
with us having a look at the front of
the Daily Star and plenty of tributes of
course to Barry Humphries and uh the
headline there that we were all
expecting Rachel goodnight possums I was
reading that Rob brydon saw him in
hospital in the last few days and said
he was making him laugh right until the
end
well yeah and his family uh said
something similar as well that he was
just completely himself until the end
and look it's been incredible reading
these uh some of these obituaries and
tributes because it is clear that this
extraordinary Talent
did have a full life a full professional
life you know he did so much this actor
this comedy genius author
um and did so much globally and touched
so many people globally and it's been
it's been interesting just to sort of
refresh or remember what why what was so
funny you know this what was so amazing
about his sort of Comedy genius and just
dipping into a few of the clips
um and a personal favorite of mine
involves
um
an interview on Lorraine involving
um a koala bear a cameraman and and a
gum nut and I think I probably will
leave it there
but it was this acidic wit an incredible
comedy timing
um just made him hilarious and of course
will be deeply missed yeah I interviewed
Dave Maiden about 10 years ago and it
was hilarious but also incredibly rude
and we could only broadcast about five
percent of it Benedict because it was so
shocking but um uh Dame Eden was
brilliant at those put downs and the
double entender
yes and I mean uh the the clip that's
been doing the round online is of course
the one uh where he was on the sofa of I
think it's Good Morning Britain or
something like that and he very
deliberately pretends to mistake uh
Dermot O'Leary for Kevin Schofield in
the the entire Studio sort of collapses
with laughter
um or of course the clip of him at the
Royal Variety performance where with uh
then Prince Charles now King Charles you
know there are many examples of him uh
being just able to deliver those comic
lines with just sort of perfection and
the mannerisms just being so on point I
mean the favorite thing that I remember
him for is that he was the only
redeeming feature from the generally
Dreadful Hobbit films where he played
the Great Goblin with the CGI and uh you
know it's it's a fantasy film big big
box office fantasy film but he delivers
a comic line where he Corners Gandalf
and says what are you going to do now
Gandalf stabs him and he looks almost to
Cameron goes here that'll do it before
he dies and that apparently was just you
know created he's just on the hole like
that it's that sort of ability to do
something like that and completely
change the timber of a situation that I
think really marks out great comic Minds
from the rest of us and it is very sad
especially you know coming in the wake
of uh the sad demise of uh Paul O'Grady
and his alter ego Lily Savage we've lost
two you know really sort of great
characters in the last couple of weeks
but it is very nice to just refresh and
to remember all all the good jokes that
they did give us because that does give
us all a bit of a lift to remember uh
remember the comic Geniuses that they
were yeah well I've been watching
watching lots of Clips um this afternoon
including that one you mentioned I think
it was it was Phillips go film this
morning wasn't it um let's move on to
the front of the mirror and uh Boris
Johnson story uh Rachel
um how would you uh assess his post
number 10 uh a few months uh I mean what
do you make of this one
first of all just to link to
um Dave Edna briefly uh brilliant
interview with Boris Johnson doing the
rounds as well well worth watching
definitely had his number
early on
um so he's living the life isn't he
um zero consequences for what happened
he'll be fine he's having one luxury
holiday after another he's got loads of
very wealthy
um friends with very Flash and fancy
Holiday Homes around the globe so he's
just basically splitting from one to the
other this one is him and his family at
a tycoon cousin's 4 100 pound a night
Villa their fourth vacation in 10 months
um and it's the home of Sam Blythe who
um helped the ex-prime minister secure a
loan uh which because credit uh
connected to facilitating a credit line
uh to the BBC Chief Richard Sharp
um over which a probe over the
appropriate ofness of that which shop
did not declare at the time
um
whether it's uh okay or not I would
suggest not but is it what do you make
of this um as a front page story
it's one of those things that sort of
emerges it's not entirely surprising
that Boris Johnson will be living it up
in La Maison Grant with you know the
rich and powerful and famous especially
those of whom uh he's already friendly
and have helped him out in the past this
isn't particularly unusual behavior from
former heads of States I think you know
uh Tony Blair used to Holiday with
Silvio Berlusconi whilst he was prime
minister and also afterwards you know
plenty of other people do it very
famously PMS end up on the sort of the
after dinner circuit making as much
money as they can uh this is just a
reminder I think of the bad old days of
the Boris Johnson Administration which
is not a period any of us necessarily
want to look back on uh if any fondness
uh the important thing I think is to
remember that he's almost certainly now
as much as he may have believed that
there was a comeback at some stage
potentially on the cards this is not a
man who is going to have high office
again
um even for Boris Johnson his powers
have sort of a comeback would be pretty
impressive he manage that and so you
know
I just I just I I wish him long life
health happiness far away from me you
know they all joke about Fiddler on the
Roof and the Czar you know just as long
as he's not forcing you know policy on
me that I disagree with then uh that you
can do whatever you want just okay
Benedict we're out of time um no
indication of any wrongdoing of course
by uh Boris Johnson and we'll speak to
you both again in half an hour thank you
very much